we're talking about apple earnings and
Tom 65 million that is the number i am
looking at because that is how many
iPhones Apple is forecast you have sold
in the last quarter we know both you and
I did our part we've got a new iPhone 6
65 million though Tom and is also
roughly the population of France that
should blow your mind poor Johnson is
our Bloomberg West editor-at-large he
crawled out of the bed in the middle of
the night in a very snow list thank you
for watching snow hill both ways uh too
pretty laughable talk about some snow I
saw you wearing a giraffe a hat in the
block I'm disappointed that you put that
away but Corey talked to us about Apple
is it all about that I phone number what
else should be we be looking for in
today's report you know this is actually
strangely for the market at least for
those who trade this stock a very
crucial quarter this is the quarter
which we're gonna have a full sale of
iphone 6 and 6 plus sales a new iphone
two years ago and two years before that
when we had iphone 4 and the iphone 3
releases we had big moves in apple's
stock we had big quarters and in both
cases of stock sold off quite a bit i
think one of the things we might walk
away from when we get the results
tonight is not just looking at the
importance of the iphone but look at the
importance of Apple in China I think it
really will illustrate the position that
Apple's in where they don't lead in
market share where they have probably
only about twenty percent market share
but about eighty percent of the
industries profits and China may indeed
be the biggest market for the iphone
we'll find out later today Corey compare
and contrast 89 some billion at
Microsoft vs apple almost double that
150 5 billion should we see a use of
cash announcement this afternoon I don't
expect anything like that from Apple
because they've already sort of laid out
their plans that way both in terms of of
repurchases and in just in terms of
deploying capital we know with whatever
they're doing in terms of managing one
of the things about their capital course
is this dispersed all over the world and
they used it in very clever ways to
provide financing for vendors for
companies like Foxconn to buy the
equipment to make the iphone special
they've been very clever about that use
of cash I wouldn't expect anything
different I do you think was notable
last night that Microsoft actually
called an end to their buyback minds you
at the end of next of 2016 but they
they're there 60 billion dollar buyback
will end by next year and I think that's
one of the reasons in After Hours the
stock traded off hey Cory looking at the
earnings yesterday from Microsoft I was
struck that you know they missed analyst
estimates for revenue on licenses for
windows and word but they still made
10.2 billion dollars that's an
incredible engine going forward even if
it's something they're slowly getting
out of yeah I think this is gonna be the
last quarter with Microsoft's benefits
certainly from the brief surprise we had
at the end of last year in pc sales
ticked up in spite of all the the
movement we have towards the world of
mobile the world of tablets but because
they stop supporting windows XP there
was a rush to do corporate upgrades and
we saw a big bump in the third quarter
lessers above in the fourth quarter that
greatly aided sought to nadella in his
first year as CEO but what we saw from
the guidance in the conference call in
particular was that that's over and then
it happened no more and when they gave
us some discussion about unbilled
revenues and things we can see that
unbilled revenues the growth and
unbilled revenues would they go to do we
know what they kindly called it and
don't call deferred revenues that growth
as kind as now as great as some of the
Bulls might have hoped and that we're
entering into a new period for Microsoft
of the the sledding is going to get
tougher yeah an appropriate analogy for
today or metaphor Corey you know what
about FX it was just a few weeks ago
that we saw Apple had to raise the price
of iphones in moscow because the ruble
had sold off is the stronger dollar
going to bite into apples or any did you
see any of that in Microsoft yesterday
we absolutely thought a Microsoft
yesterday we're gonna see it probably a
little bit an apple and we're gonna see
a lot of it over the course of really
the next four months I mean we're
talking about fourth-quarter FX now
what's happening in the first quarter
already so I think for a handful of tech
companies that sell particularly into
Europe companies like Cisco where nearly
a third of sales are into Europe they're
gonna see some serious FX headwinds and
no one's really counted it into their
models just yet so we could be for some
negative surprises in a big way for a
lot of the big enterprise tech company
certainly a big wild card Corey we
dearly appreciate your getting out of
bed at 3am to join us